welcome back you're watching inking live
from the heart of the city now the
considerable warming of relations
between Cuba in the United States has
helped bring huge change not just to
those two nations but throughout much of
Central and South America at least part
of the credit needs to go to Panama
where President a farmer held this
meeting with cuba's President Raul
Castro last April the first time the
leaders of the two countries had met for
more than half a century but alongside
the economic opportunities comes huge
uncertainty over the potentially
devastating impact of the Zika virus
palomar is one of 27 countries in the
region where Zika is currently spreading
isabel de st. malo de Alvarado is
Panama's vice president and foreign
minister and joins me now Panama is the
biggest free trade zone in the Western
Hemisphere there's been a slowdown in
global trade is that concerning you well
panama has a very robust and diverse
economy and actually we've been growing
steadily for the past 10 15 years last
year we grew six and a half percent and
I've you take the last 15 years we've
grown up eight and a half percent so due
to the structure of our economy and
we've managed to continue to expand and
to continue to grow I do not believe the
slowdown and trader it's really
affecting Panama we are lucky and very
fortunate and happy that we will be
inaugurating the expanded canal by the
middle of this year this is great news
for the world and for World Trade and
that our geographic position has certain
advantages our port system are our
logistics sector so luckily enough I
wouldn't think that that's affecting us
the expanded canal of course are these
huge new super freighters which was
supposed to be carrying Chinese goods to
the rest of the world Chinese exports of
course under a bit of a cloud is there
going to be the traffic that you're
anticipating we anticipate the same
countries that are currently users of
the canal to remain the most important
users of the canal and then that is to
the united states china chili through
and some other countries however there
is there is awaiting the
right now so we do not anticipate that
effective we expect the expanded canal
just to triple the capacity and to make
free to make trade less costly because
once larger ships can go through a
faster secure route their costs diminish
as in yes China is one of the most
important users of the canal now
mentioned in our introduction there you
you would present you help bring
together Raul Castro and President Obama
just what impact is the opening up of
Cuba and half to the central america and
caribbean region I think what what's
happening between Cuba and the United
States is great news for for the
Americas it's finding our common areas
where there is diversity is finding a
possibility of working together we have
have a lot of a potential as a region we
have a lot of challenges as well but the
more we can discuss our differences and
our common issues and find common ways
to address them the more the region can
improve so it is great news the credit
goes whole actually to Cuba and the
United States and then you support that
the rest of region can can provide we
will just be there because it's part of
what we believe will take the region
further in terms of development I would
about the Zika virus as we mentioned
that you have had outbreaks in Panama
how concerned I do you have the
resources to deal with it we have the
resources fortunately resources is not
the issue for Panama we have few cases
not the dramatic situation there are in
other countries Panama we've had a
long-standing tradition of fighting this
type of diseases as a tropical country
our ministry of health is very well
prepared for these types of situations
we are actually cooperating with other
countries in terms of our knowledge
regarding the confrontation of these
types of situation the cabinet approved
an alert degree last year not because of
on readiness but to be prepared to risk
on the faster we've taken the necessary
health measures and and we're prepared
to deal with the situation and to
cooperate we are concerned however it's
a situation of concern to the region and
we're just prepared to cooperate with
any country that requires our assistant
and do and to ensure that Panama is safe
in our citizens are safe with this
situation all right Isabella descent
malo de Alvarado thank you very much for
joining me it's good thank you very much